[Music]
Iran lied about never having a nuclear
weapons program the Iran deal the
nuclear deal is based on lies it's based
on Iranian lies and Iranian deception
and in a few days time
president Trump will decide we'll make a
decision on what to do with the nuclear
deal I'm sure you'll do the right thing
the right thing for the United States
the right thing for Israel and the right
thing for the Peace of the world that is
just not an acceptable situation and
I've been saying that's happening
they're not sitting back idly they're
setting off missiles which they say are
for television purposes I don't think so
the Israeli prime minister with a
detailed layout of evidence he says
there's Raley's got from Iran you heard
the Israeli ambassador to the u.s.
saying in recent weeks they've been
sharing it with the US the Iranians
pushing back on Twitter today breaking
the boy who can't stop crying wolf is at
it again undeterred by cartoon fiasco at
the United Nations General Assembly you
can only fool some of the people so many
times referring to a speech Netanyahu
gave there but the seriousness here is
that 12 days from now the president of
the United States decides whether to
pull out of the Iran nuclear deal let's
bring in our panel guy Benson political
editor at townhall comm host of the new
show Benson and harf on Fox News radio
which begins next Monday congratulations
on that more Eliason national political
correspondent of National Public Radio
and Molly Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalists okay Maura you heard the
ambassador here saying how serious it is
with the reams of information that he
says the Israelis got about a nuclear
program that essentially was designed to
make a nuclear weapon right and what
Netanyahu did today an incredibly simple
clear exposition with the big letters
and the graphics was to give the reasons
why the Iran deal was a bad deal and
should never have been entered into he
didn't really explain what happens after
the u.s. gets out but
certainly corroborated all of president
Trump's instincts and everybody who's
talked to the president expects that he
will pull out on May 12 you know are
some time before a lot of articles a lot
of people have been saying that the
Prime Minister was essentially doing
that for an audience of one for
president Trump oh yeah I noticed that
was said earlier in this show and I
actually disagree with that I think
Trump actually has a pretty good idea of
what he wants to do the real conflict is
with European countries who really do
want to uphold the deal and who do want
to find a way to keep it going
learning that this deal was broken I
mean if failing to be honest going into
the deal means that the deal is no good
and it is interesting that we've been
told for so many years Iran is in
compliance Iran is in compliance that
echo-chamber from the Obama
administration is very good at getting
its talking points out they've been
saying over and over that there's
nothing you can do because Iran is in
compliance well when today Netanyahu
says this is built on a throne of lies
then they say oh we always knew that
well you have to pick one or the other
either they're complying or they there's
a complete falsehood at the foundation
of this deal right
so the jcpoa the Iran nuclear deal
structure says essentially that you had
to say the honest statements at the
beginning that was the first compliance
if you're not complying with that then
the whole thing's not in compliance
that's right so it was a prerequisite
for the deal going into implementation
in the very first place and the
requirement of Iran was to attest fully
and completely and transparently what
they had done in regards to their
nuclear program in the past and the
Iranians lied through their teeth saying
that they never had a nuclear weapons
program and now we see today I think
very strong incontrovertible evidence
laid out very clearly from the Israelis
that that was just not true they the
Iranians absolutely had this program up
through 2003 then they broke it off into
overt and covert and crucially the same
person who oversaw the illicit illegal
program that they did not existed is
still in control of the covert side of
the nuclear program I thought it was a
devastating and powerful performance
today from from Netanyahu and it should
influence that information should
influence our president here is the
French president characterizing days ago
Iran nuclear deal there is an existing
framework called the jcpoa to control
the nuclear activity of Iran we signed
it at the initiative of the United
States we signed it boss the United
States and France that is why we cannot
say we should get rid of it but we
should not abandon it without having
something substantial and more
substantial instead so I guess the real
question Mara is can this evidence force
or push the European allies France we
saw Angela Merkel here we're going the
president's going to London to see the
British Prime Minister can it forced
them to get on with a new round of
sanctions outside of the Iran deal that
is the big question they haven't wanted
to they were willing to build on extra
protections about ballistic missiles or
maybe about Iran's meddling in the
region but they want to build on this
deal they don't want to start from
scratch and that's the question can the
United States get the Europeans to agree
to extra sanctions more and don't forget
the president has another deadline and
it's midnight tonight to see if he's
going to continue those exemptions for
the steel and aluminum tariffs against
the EU that matters when he's asking the
Europeans to cooperate on something else
like the Iran nuclear deal plus I also
think it's interesting my chrome points
out that they signed this treaty at the
USS behest and it is important that we
be good with our word and why learning
that other people aren't being good with
their word is important it also speaks
to why it was such a mistake to not take
this to the Senate and have a broad
public discussion where people could
really hash out what we wanted to do
with Iran this is not a treaty it's very
easy to get in and out of it precisely
because it's not a Senate approved to
Senate ratified treaty it's a good
warning but for Donald Trump that if he
wants to sign a peace treaty he does
need to make that public case and get
everybody on board so we can have a good
treaty in North Korea yeah it was kind
of a backwards disapproval by the Senate
and in the construct that was put
together I want to turn topics to North
Korea here's the president on the
meeting up coming he says in the meeting
sites
we're looking at various countries
including Singapore and we are also
talking about the possibility of the DMZ
peace house freedom house and there's
something that I thought was intriguing
there's something that I like about it
because you're there you're actually
there where if things work out there's a
great celebration to be had so he's
looking at the images here meantime the
South Korean President had this to say
according to Reuters translated by
Reuters president Trump should win the
Nobel Peace Prize what we need is only
peace there's some good feelings I guess
coming out of South Korea from from that
meeting well if this does work out of
course the president deserves the Nobel
Peace Prize the last president got one
for doing literally nothing this would
be something I'm among the crowd that is
pleased to see these developments but
skeptical of the North Koreans and their
willingness to keep their word speaking
of outlaw regimes that do not but the
South Koreans are at the table as well
the handshake was historic and it does
seem like president Trump's unusual
approach to foreign policy has at the
very least brought both sides together
not sure what the Americans might be
willing to do and here we are definite
positive steps but a lot farther to go
yeah trust but verify
yeah the nuclear site that they're
closing down is a nuclear site that that
in part collapsed so you have to kind of
look it right and the administration has
been very good at sending these messages
look when we we know how difficult it is
we know that they've cheated on every
other deal we're gonna walk away if we
have to but the president now seems to
be getting super optimistic he's already
talking about the victory party on the
celebration that he wants to have right
there at the DMZ so the question is is
he really really willing to walk away if
he can't get the kind of assurances that
he needs from the North Koreans I think
there is an issue though to if they were
to do this on site it ramps up the
pressure in a way that could motivate
people toward a good solution not just
that it would be great for him the
surroundings would then force the that
ability of the deal
it might help contribute it to that but
it's absolutely true if we're talking
about Iran being a regime that lies we
have such a great history of the North
Korea
being deployed this and falsifying what
they're doing and so it is good that
people are being cautious I think it is
true though that a year ago close to a
year ago we were talking about how
Donald Trump is supposedly bringing us
to the brink of nuclear war we are in a
very different place and that alone is
important people should think about what
about his foreign policy has led us to
this place is amazing when he talks
about the images and the power of images
clearly he knows that part of it